just to give you some flavor of the kind
of vaccines that
potentially may come through over the
next
year or so there are the messenger rna
vaccines
that was the subject of the pfizer
announcement on monday
these vaccines essentially send a coded
message to the immune system
to tell it to make covid antibodies
there are the adenoviral vector vaccines
these insert the covid spike
protein that's the key antigen the key
protein which
allows humans to recognize
the virus and allows the virus to bind
with with the human cell
those are inserted into a harmless or
weakened common cold virus and
that again stimulates antibody
production
then there are the protein adjuvants
protein adjuvanted vaccines these are
slightly older technology
and they are effectively pieces of the
covid virus protein
broken up and when given with an
adjuvant
they stimulate antibody production and
then finally
there is the option of a whole virus
approach
which is where you take the virus and
you kill it
and then it is safely injectable and it
stimulates antibody production
so there are many different approaches
many different manufacturers
and we're just at the beginning of this
journey and it is that
complexity of what we hope will have
soon
versus what we hope will have within
nine to twelve months that makes the job
of the joint committee on vaccination
and immunisation
very challenging indeed but a terribly
important job
in terms of then determining after
authorization
who should receive the vaccine and
professor lim
is here to explain to you some more
about that
thank you very much as jonathan says the
joint committee on vaccination and
immunization
jcvi is an independent expert committee
and we're constituted to advise the
secretary of state
on the provision of vaccination and
immunization
during this pandemic we've been meeting
weekly recently
to appraise ourselves of all the
available
scientific information that is relevant
and
to be able to make the best possible
recommendation in the most timely
manner this is all on an independent
basis i just want to describe
the current interim recommendation from
jcvi
regarding the priority groups for
vaccination when a corporate vaccine
becomes available
the current phase that we would suggest
or recommend
is a phase where we prioritize the most
vulnerable individuals in society
specifically people who are most likely
to die from severe covet 19 infection
and we take into account the important
role of the nhs
and social care as well a further
consideration in our prioritization
is that the program needs to be
recognizable it needs to be
understandable to everybody
and importantly it needs to be
deliverable
we've reviewed data on how the pandemic
is progressing in the uk
the risk factors that are associated
with severe disease from corporate 19
and mathematical models that have looked
at
different vaccination strategies and how
those might work
i'll just come on to the priority groups
as they are defined at the moment
and i just want to underline that these
are interim
current recommendations and they are may
change
as we get more information at the very
top of our priority list are care home
residents
and people who work in care homes
this reflects the devastating impact of
corbett 19
in our care homes as we all know
following on from care home residents we
will prioritize
older individuals going down age bands
down from 80 plus year olds to
60 plus year olds and the reason for
this is because
age is by far the strongest risk factor
associated
with severe coveting disease
following on from those who are age 65
and above
we will then prioritize individuals
particularly adults i should say
who have an underlying health condition
that puts them at risk of corvette 19
disease
falling on from there we will keep going
down the age bands
to individuals who are 50 years and
above
that describes phase one of the program
and phase one as i say is aimed at
protecting the most vulnerable
if phase one is completed then we will
have
protected hopefully over 99 percent
of those individuals who are at risk of
dying from covet 19.
we have not decided yet on who else
should be vaccinated
beyond phase one that's not to say that
they shouldn't be vaccinated but simply
that we haven't decided yet on
prioritization
and that's because we need more
information hopefully
on the vaccines who they are good for
and whether they protect against
transmission or infection